So the burrito distribution governs all sorts of other things too.
I mentioned
it governs the popularity of box,
the sales of books,
but it also,
it also characterizes the distribution of everything that people produce.
So if you think of creative production of any sort of artistic production,
industrial production,
it doesn't matter.
Almost everything fails
and a few things succeed beyond anyone's wildest imagination.
Apple's a good example of that.
No,
I mean the iPhone,
they have their competitors,
but it's an extraordinarily dominant product and they rake in billions of
dollars,
I think.
I don't know if apple is valued at $1 trillion,
but it's close to that.
And that's a lot of money.
And I think,
if I remember correctly,
it's something like this.
I probably have the figures wrong,
but like the top 40 people,
the richest 40 people in the world have as much money as the bottom 2 billion
right now.
You know,
it's not like they're stuffing their mattresses with that money,
or they have a skyscraper full of cash.
That money is out in the economy doing whatever money does.
So you know you can't spend $28 billion.
So,
and sometimes you can even do some good with it.
You know,
Bill Gates seems to be doing something reasonable with his money.
But the reason I'm telling you this is because one of the things you should know
is that this proclivity for inequality is pervasive among the creative products
of human beings.
It's the case with with goals scored in hockey.
My son told me,
and he's a reliable source on hockey statistics that,
okay,
if Wayne Gretzky,
if you don't count any of the points that Wayne Gretzky managed with scoring is
still had enough points just with assistance to have more points than any hockey
player that ever played.
So you know,
even at the upper end of,
of of the distribution,
there's some person who's Ha,
they're so good at what they do.
And then there's another person that's so much better than them that it's not
even comparable.
And so,
and the benefits flow to people who are in that position.
And you can understand why.
I would say,
because I know,
let's say you start writing and you get a book and a rare things,
very weird things to have happened.
And then some people read it and they like it.
And then of course it's much more likely that you'll get a next book.
And if people like that,
while it's even more likely that you'll get a third book,
and then people start to know who you are,
and then because they know who you are,
they phone you up on offer you opportunities and your network grows.
And it's like this exponential increase in your reach and your capacity for
production and more and more flows to you.